another question this one this is my
question are there some relatively
elementary concepts that you've recently
had a new insight on so for example my i
don't know if you know my brother
sebastian he's a professor at u of t as
well in math finance he was telling me
kurt you know only recently maybe last
year i thought i realized oh the
triangle inequality is actually about a
triangle he would only just use the
formula
also recently okay the jay cubby and
determinant the j j kobien is actually
like
it's like a linear map of of what is
that point
doing
close instead of just okay think of it
as an abstraction of slopes and stuff
yeah so do you have an example
sorry of what of things that i've only
recently understood no no of something
you have understood you've used before
but then maybe you've come to a
different understanding of and you say
oh that's an interesting way of thinking
about it i didn't see that before
it happens all the time
well i wish it would have happened all
the times when it happens it's a great
day not all day is a great day but there
is the occasional great day
uh
you know every time you learn some
something has
a higher meaning it's it's or
more meaning than you thought it's great
news
it happens all the time in the life in
the professional
life of a
scientist
though not every day
okay
um
well
uh
i'll give you an example which somehow
which i think also partially involves
you so um
a few years ago i was asked to give a
10 minutes talk or something
to a
i don't even remember what was the event
but you were there
oh you remember that mentorship event or
something like that i don't remember
that's what that was that's right and i
thought what would i talk about and i
well okay the truth is that i have some
list of uh
ready-made topics that i can talk about
you know
if you ask me to talk in front of high
school students i sort of have a number
of topics that are ready okay
uh but nothing really fit
and also sometimes i i get bored of
myself
so i have to occasionally add something
so i said okay why don't i talk about a
prisoner's dilemma
and um
so i i mentioned the prisoner's dilemma
in five minutes or so
and it's a very light map right it's
hardly math
it's so light that it's hardly math
but then i realized that it's that it
has a
profound i guess the economists have
always understood that
they always thought it was important but
i realized it only relatively recently
so that was what is it three four years
ago
i only then understood how
profoundly
important it is
so
you know
the prisoner's dilemma is some numerical
example
where
you have
two sides two people a and b
and they can choose whether to
cooperate or betray each one chooses
independently
whether to cooperate with the other or
betray the other
and if you look at the numbers
each one no matter what the other does
would prefer to betray
and as a result both of them would
betray
and the overall outcome is worse to both
of them again i'm not describing the
whole thing i'm not telling the numbers
i'm just saying
there is this situation where if each
one acts selfishly
it's worth for it's worse for both
and
well
it has huge philosophical implications
you know there is a whole a whole um
uh
political class
that believes
that people should be acting selfishly
because if each one acts selfishly it's
actually for the best of the
uh
for
better for everyone
that's somehow the foundation of the
belief in free
markets uh so
uh
so so yes i am actually still a great
believer in free markets
i actually still greatly believe that
free markets are a good thing
but there is a little asterisk
sorry that's not duality that's an
asterisk so there is a little asterisk
asterisk and the asterisk says
provided somebody arranges so that free
markets when each one acts selfishly
you will not be led into prisoner's
dilemma
dilemmas you will be
you will be you'll be you'll stay out
and
ah
and your selfish acts will actually
benefit
the overall good so i mean this asterisk
here is the prisoner's dilemma
ah sorry i well okay yes yes yes i get
it anyway uh
and you think it's a small asterisk but
the more you think about it you realize
it's actually a huge asterisk it
completely changes the picture
uh and it's much much much more common
you think of it as an esoteric example
but then you realize that it's
everywhere
so it's actually a very very big
asterisk
and
i think i realized it relatively
recently